[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres 51 départements en vigilance
orange canicule dans toute
l'ile-de-france aussi une canicule qui
devrait s'étendre et se renforcer nous
ferons un point sur les gestes à adopter
pour se protéger des élections
législatives en privant ce week-end mais
pas de répit pour les nouveaux députés
cette semaine ils font leur rentrée à
l'assemblée nationale et puis le
week-end dernier un collectif de maman
organisé une marche contre la violence
que subit le peuple qu'elle subit
attrape une manifestation qui fait suite
à plusieurs incidents ayant eu lieu ces
dernières semaines
vous avez eu chaud voire très chaud
aujourd'hui c'est normal une vague de
chaleur traverse la france
durant cette période de canicule il faut
savoir se protéger les bons conseils
avec stéphane servant le département des
yvelines comme 50 autres vient de passer
au niveau orange de l' alerte canicule
là nous sommes en alerte niveau 3 donc
les personnes à protéger en priorité
sont les bébés et les personnes âgées
les températures atteignent jusqu'à 36
degrés pour la journée de mercredi
pas forcément agréable de manger en
terrasse aujourd'hui on déjà l'intérieur
à
en période de canicule il est plus que
recommandé de rechercher la fraîcheur de
bien s'hydrater de bien protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables enfants
et personnes âgées pour les bébés le
chapeau les lunettes de soleil sont
obligatoires métro est possible d'agir
short tee-shirt et surtout les
rafraîchir avec un linge mouillé ou une
eau thermale pour les personnes âgées il
est important de fermer ses volets de
rester dans une pièce fraîche et
climatisées et de bien boire
enfin il est important d'éviter de faire
du sport à cause de la chaleur et de la
pollution
on passe à la politique des législatives
viennent de prendre fin
pas de répit pour les députés il faut
déjà qu'ils se mettent au travail nous
les avons suivis lors de leurs premiers
pas à l'assemblée nationale un panneau
une flèche pour indiquer la direction
celle de l'assemblée nationale quelques
heures seulement après sa victoire dans
les yvelines
aurore bergé parmi les premières à
découvrir sous le soleil le palais
bourbon une prise de repères qui à 30
ans à peine en rappelle d'autres n'y a
pas les parents qui m'accompagne donc ça
va j'ai grandi depuis l'école mais
c'est beaucoup d'émotions c'est très
solennelle moi je suis déjà rentrée à
l'assemblée nationale mais ça n'a rien à
voir d'entrée pour la première france
donc dépit de la nation pose devant les
photographes et une interview à la
chaîne
après les jardins des quatre colonnes la
nouvelle députée dispose désormais d'une
mallette avec écharpe et règlement
intérieur
vous allez devoir le lire et le
respectent et dernière étape de la
visite l'hémicycle je pense que c'est
important s'est imprégné de la solennité
des lieux pour comprendre ce qu'on
attend de nous pour comprendre
la gravité du moment la responsabilité
qui doit être la nôtre non cas voilà
c'était c'est symbolique mais c'est
aussi très important pour bien intégrer
le travail que l'on va faire à partir
d'aujourd'hui en tout ils sont 400 à
découvrir l'assemblée nationale cette
semaine parmi eux nadia et et béatrice
piron de la république en marche député
de la 11e et 3e circonscription des
yvelines pour les élus de la majorité
présidentielle l'apprentissage se
poursuivra ce week-end avec un séminaire
de travail prévue à paris on prend la
direction de trappes ou le week end
dernier un collectif de maman organisé
une marche contre la violence que subit
la ville une manifestation qui fait
suite à plusieurs incidents ayant lieu
d'ailleurs eu lieu ces dernières
semaines
elles étaient une trentaine une
trentaine de mères à manifester le
week-end dernier devant la place courbet
à trappes
pourquoi ce rassemblement elle souhaite
faire entendre leur voix face à la
violence qui se manifeste à trappes pour
aider les enfants d'avoir la santé et
une longue vie parce que tu as this bas
il se contrôle pas il peut se blesser et
la tempête des handicapés ou qui peut
mourir alors pour ça j'ai dit non on
doit ou les mamans de se mettre ensemble
de dire aux pit stop
maintenant j'ai compris ce qu'on veut
nous les mamans que vous avez la tête
cette manifestation fait suite à des
échauffourées ayant eu lieu devant la
mosquée de trappes il ya en moi un homme
avait été poignardé dans le dos une
violence qui rappelle la ferme où ça un
jeune collégien de 14 ans mort après
avoir pris le bal perdu des affaires que
le maire de trappes trou inacceptables
inacceptables au plan ou plan humain des
événements violents qui ont eu lieu il
ya une quinzaine de jours un deux soirs
deux soirs consécutifs où des des
personnes ont été blessées et blessé
grièvement et donc aurait dit qu on
était passé de rossa de l'action
criminelle et que ça ce n'est pas
tolérable et que le fait que les mamans
un certain nombre de mamans et souhaité
exprimer leur désaccord avec cette
violence est était un élément
extrêmement positif un rassemblement
soutenue par l'acteur omar sy originaire
de la ville
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines organisée une rencontre entre
des professionnels des métiers du soin
et de la rééducation
le but recherché des nouveaux
professionnels engagés
zoom sur les métiers de la santé de la
rééducation une rencontre entre des
personnes en recherche d'emploi et des
professionnels du secteur organisée par
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines ces échanges permettent de
découvrir ses activités du paramédical
on a exprimé auprès de nous à manque de
personnel infirmier en particulier à la
même chez eux elle a donc à la ferrière
sur wii les métiers
d'infirmiers et contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser on a du mal à recruter
visiblement sur ces métiers là
à 28 ans olivia a quitté son poste de
secrétaire pour une reconversion
professionnelle
elle a participé à cette présentation
pour obtenir des informations sur la
formation à suivre sans effectivement
attiré par principalement le métier
d'aide-soignante
ou le métier d'auxiliaire de
puériculture ergothérapeute
kinésithérapeute psychomotricien
plusieurs professions tensions sur saint
quentin en yvelines en particulier la
kinésithérapie ou encore les postes
d'infirmières ou d'aide-soignante c'est
un métier où les professionnels
choisissent aussi beaucoup de
s'installer en libéral choisissent pas
forcément le salariat et donc du coup
c'est nous on a un fort besoin en
rééducation dans nos établissements et
c'est vrai que c'est un métier où on est
un petit peu plus s'ils ont de grandes
difficultés aujourd'hui pour le
recrutement ces métiers sont en tension
parce que les conditions de travail sont
difficiles les rémunérations ne sont pas
forcément hauteur de ce que l'on
souhaite
prochain événement un zoom sur les
métiers de services à la personne ce
jeudi 22 juin la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines
cinq mois après la vente du réseau câblé
par saint quentin en yvelines à sfr me
réunion publique était organisée jeudi
dernier
l'occasion d'en apprendre un peu plus
sur cette collaboration
je viens aujourd'hui pour enseigner sur
l'avenir de la fibre voir cantonné si un
autre opérateur qu'être qu'on peut avoir
comme fibres et dans quel délai pour
avoir des informations sur justement ce
qui va se passer quand au haut débit à
51 depuis le temps qu'on en parle et
qu'on voit rien venir
espérons que cette fois là ça va être ta
bonne et puis qu'on pourra enfin avoir
du très haut débit chez nous le très
haut débit est plus qu'attendue sur
saint quentin en yvelines
pour preuve des habitants venus en
nombre à cette première réunion publique
c'est un haut débit qui n'est pas en
fibre optique jusqu'au bout mais qu'il
ya une terminaison en câble
donc il faut expliquer que ceux haut
débit il a les mêmes compétences que le
haut débit qui va en fibre optique
jusqu'aux cfr qui a obtenu le réseaux
câblés numericable pour l'opérateur il
s'agit d'un programme d'investissement
de 2 5 millions d'euros
on a à peu près 7000 prises qui ont été
rénovées qui vont passer qui sont passés
à 100 mégabits et après on va les faire
passer ou un gigabit les infrastructures
sont prêtes pour le 1 gigabit c'est
simplement
un sujet de systèmes d'information on
doit contacter tous les clients pour
savoir si ni leur box peut supporter ou
pas si elle doit être changée ou pas une
réunion publique sous tension certains
habitants ayant fait remonter des
problèmes déjà existants sur le
territoire
pour le moment ça fonctionne assez mal
que ce soit à la télévision ou par
internet et ça correspond pas si vous
voulez ou besoin que l'on a et à ce que
nous a proposée on est dans les 30 mégas
donc de mon temps et 5 mégas descendants
je constate que l a beaucoup qui se
plaignent par rapport à achat ils ont
beaucoup moins donc on sent un peu
privilégié le déploiement du très haut
débit est prévu jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2017 ou début 2010 8 sur
certains facteurs et on passe au sport
avec du baseball dimanche dernier les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux
recevez rouen pour la 9e journée du
championnat de première division
pas de miracle pour les inhumant teint
malgré ses défaites montigny le
bretonneux conserve quand même la
quatrième place et devrait se maintenir
en fin de saison
mais le coach de l'équipe reste prudent
on n'a fait que la moitié de la saison
là on commence la deuxième partie tout
peut arriver maintenant voilà je pense
qu'on est quand même bien placé
aujourd'hui on a le fait d'avoir fait
une très bonne première partie de saison
ça nous permet d'être plus serein
maintenant comme je vous ai dit dans le
baseball tout peut arriver et n'importe
quelle équipe peut battre n'importe
quelle autre donc il faut quand même
qu'on garde les pieds sur terre et que
on maintienne le niveau qu'on a qu'on a
pratiqué sur la première partie de
saison
c'est la fin 7-8 le journal merci de
nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]